[Music]
it's a celebration selena gomez turns
the big three-o
[Music]
leave it to selena to party with her
pals the singer rang in her 30th
birthday with a star-studded guest list
that has us having major fomo selena
kicked off her b-day with taylor swift
in an intimate dinner for two where it
appears t swift gave her bestie a gift
to open at the table selena looked
happier than ever laughing with her gal
pal and wrote in the caption 30 nerdy
and worthy my personal life and my
family and my friends i'm just i'm in a
really happy place it's been good and
sale kept the good times rolling
[Music]
when she wasn't on the dance floor
selena was snapping pics in a shimmery
halter neck dress next to girl pool's
harmony tivodad
then there's this stunning close-up with
sophia carson and selina's smile says it
all thank you i appreciate i try
the photo stations seem to be a hit with
guests check out ava max striking a pose
and the fierceness continued with
selena's bff francia raisa smoldering
with her two sisters at the party we're
not surprised francia stepped out to
celebrate cell's milestone the two have
a special bond after the grownish
actress donated her kidney to selena
back in 2017. the tough times the good
times all of it meanwhile camila cabello
gives a glimpse of cell's birthday cake
featuring an adorable throwback of
little selena during her barney and
friends days
oh my goodness yeah it's amazing and we
are loving the little details at her
dirty 30. a little bit of everything
lily singh showed off her drink of
choice for the night in a custom red cup
etched with the late selena
quintanilla's signature font
[Music]
we knew selena's 30th would be a party
to attend just a month before she and
her only murders in the building
co-stars told et what she had in store
for the big occasion
what are our plans for selena's 30th
birthday are you really at home in bed
by the time you guys aren't throwing you
said you throw a wild card well i'll
just be getting in when it starts yeah i
hope it happens by 10 a.m so i can
celebrate
[Music]
you